A newcomer on the tourism scene is no doubt Rwanda,...
...which most people still connect with genocide and atrocities...
...committed during the last civil war.
However, Rwanda has changed.
This small but charming country has many attractions.
One of them is gorilla trekking in the Parc National de Volcans.
Trekking is physically demanding...
...because it entails a fair amount of hours...
...walking through the forest with guides.
As you wind your way through hanging vines and moss-covered trees,...
...you may see golden monkeys, buffaloes and birds.
The highlight is time spent with the gentle giant gorillas.
Watching them care for their young is very moving.
The famous gorilla research pioneer, Dian Fossey,...
...whose life was filmed in the Hollywood movie, Gorillas in the Mist,...
...was buried here after poachers murdered her in 1985.
At the end of your visit,...
...you will understand why she lived in this forest for 18 years...
...among these fantastic animals.